Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
"Non è giusto che",
lo scrivo alla lavagna.
Davanti ci sono 80 bambini,
sono quattro classi
di una scuola primaria.
Il tema è l'educazione alla legalità,
ma la parola legalità non mi convince.
Perché legalità richiama obbedienza,
come è giusto che sia.
Credo che il vero universale
biografico sia un altro,
sia il senso di ingiustizia
che sentiamo tutti sin da piccoli,
anche a due o tre anni,
quando subiamo il primo torto:
scattiamo, reagiamo.
Penso che sia quello,
il punto di partenza.
In fondo, sappiamo che anche i ragazzi
che scelsero di fare i partigiani
lo fecero per quello: per un torto,
per un senso di ingiustizia,
prima di aderire a un grande ideale.
Chiedo a quei bambini
di completare la frase:
in un attimo, la lavagna si riempie.
Voglio portarli, poco a poco,
a scrivere una lettera al sindaco, Rocco,
che il giorno dopo verrà, leggerà
e risponderà ai bambini.
Ma devo governare quel flusso,
perché "non è giusto che si muoia" -
capisco cosa intendi,
però forse vuol dire che amiamo la vita.
"Non è giusto che ci sia
sporco per terra in giro":
Fuocherello.
Ma è colpa del sindaco?
Non è colpa sua, i bambini
sono sempre molto onesti.
E dicono "Ok, è colpa di chi sporca,
ma allora cosa possiamo
chiedere al sindaco?
Forse di aumentare
i cestini in giro per strada"
Sì, i bambini sono contenti
di aver trovato una richiesta legittima
da portare al sindaco.
Il gioco che faccio
con i gruppi è un po' questo:
punto il compasso al centro,
e provo ad allargarlo più che posso,
perché devo scoprire
qual è il loro potere,
fin dove possono arrivare.
Devo crederci prima di loro
perché loro non sanno,
non pensano di averne.
Se brucia l'Amazzonia non è giusto,
ma non possiamo farci nulla,
quegli 80 bambini
non potranno farci nulla.
Stare su quello vuol dire, di fatto,
vivere l'impotenza, la frustrazione,
mentre so che quei bambini
possono cambiare il paese in cui vivono,
possono chiedere delle cose
al loro sindaco.
Se anche, come succede a quell'età,
senti di non avere alcun potere,
in realtà uno ce l'hai sempre:
è il potere della sincronizzazione,
perché un bambino che scrive
una lettera al sindaco
forse riceve una risposta;
ma 80 bambini insieme
portano il sindaco una mattina
a scuola con loro a parlarne.
Guardiamo fuori dalla finestra,
e chiedo a questi ragazzi
di una quarta superiore:
cosa vedete, là dove c'è un parcheggio?
Per allenarci a vedere l'invisibile,
per superare il ricatto del presente,
la forma così evidente,
che in qualche modo
ci fa sembrare le cose inevitabili,
ci siamo allenati,
abbiamo fatto degli esercizi.
Uno di questi è prendere un oggetto
di uso comune, come un frigorifero.
E poi, chiedo loro: "A cosa serve?"
"Serve a conservare il cibo".
Ma una volta non l'avevamo,
e abbiamo sempre conservato il cibo.
In quali altri modi,
se rinunciamo al frigorifero,
possiamo svolgere quella funzione?
Poco a poco, i ragazzi
trovano dieci, poi dodici,
poi quindici forme alternative
della funzione "conservare cibo".
A quel punto rompo il frigo. Non va più.
Un frigorifero che non fa più
il frigorifero, cos'altro può fare?
In un attimo sono
più veloci, più reattivi.
Il gioco diventa:
armadio; libreria; fioriera;
acquario; vasca da bagno; bara.
Perché a quell'età,
con la morte, si scherza.
Questo la facciamo a scuola:
credo che la scuola sia
il luogo perfetto per immaginare.
Perché il suo limite è quello
di lavorare su due dimensioni.
Quaderno, foglio, lavagna:
tutto è in due dimensioni,
quindi è sempre carente
rispetto alla realtà.
In realtà è un punto di forza,
quando devi immaginare.
Insomma, studiare geografia
è deludente rispetto a viaggiare;
ma studiare geografia
per immaginare un viaggio
è già un'altra cosa.
Forse, l'errore in cui cadiamo
è pensare che il sapere, e la cultura,
servano soprattutto a riconoscere le cose.
"Quello è un quadro cubista",
"Quello è un capitello d'oro", e così via.
Non pensiamo a immaginare mondi,
e alternative, a questo presente.
Eppure, sono gli artisti stessi
che provano a contenere il nostro
desiderio di riconoscere e basta,
a volte titolando i loro quadri
in modo sorprendente e spiazzante,
come a dire:
"Non devi riconoscere quello che c'è":
magari chiediti cosa senti,
mentre guardi quello che guardi .
Mi viene in mente
il famoso quadro di Magritte,
in cui disegna un'enorme pipa
e che si chiama "Questa non è una pipa".
Ha ragione Magritte:
è un quadro, non è una pipa.
"Allora, se quello non è un parcheggio,
cos'altro ci vedete?",
chiedo a questi ragazzi,
e a queste ragazze,
perché ho avuto mandato
dell'amministrazione
di riprogettare quell'area
fuori dalla scuola;
e sogno che disegnino un'area verde,
perché lì fuori c'è anche un giardino.
Sarebbe bello un parco
che circonda la scuola.
Ma vedo che alcuni fanno proprio fatica.
Capisco che spostarsi dal comfort
dell'evidente e del presente,
entrare nel terreno incerto
dell'ipotetico e del possibile
è difficile, non è per tutti.
Richiede fatica.
Forse è un errore anche nostro,
di adulti e istituzioni,
che tendiamo a dare il presente
come se fosse l'equazione del passato,
una sequenza di eventi
che deterministicamente
portano al qui e ora,
come se non ci fossero
altri presenti alternativi possibili.
Invece capisco che manca il racconto
di quel gioco di ipotesi,
dubbi, inciampi, errori,
progetti che precedono
la realizzazione delle cose,
e ti fanno capire
che questo che vediamo oggi
è solo uno dei presenti possibili.
Altri potevano accadere.
Quando, nei gruppi in cui riprogettiamo
una piazza, una scuola, una biblioteca,
lavoriamo insieme,
ci diamo un metodo
che è un po' l'antitesi
di questo ratificare la realtà,
illustrare in modo
didascalico il presente.
In questo metodo, pur essendo ricercatore,
abbandoniamo l'analisi,
perché l'analisi è fatta di dati,
quindi è sempre retrospettiva.
Abbiamo bisogno di visioni,
di qualcosa che guardi in avanti,
e si nutra di immagini e desideri.
I desideri non li conosciamo subito,
li dobbiamo scoprire insieme.
Dobbiamo abilitare il sogno
a occhi aperti.
Dobbiamo usare un linguaggio particolare,
che spesso è - poetico, lirico.
Non è sarcastico, perché il sarcasmo
uccide l'immaginazione:
è presuntuoso se ci pensate.
Usiamo il micro e il macro,
nel senso che il macro
relativizza il micro,
guardiamo gli altri modi di fare scuola,
di fare biblioteca, di fare piazza,
così magari scopriamo
quello che davvero desideriamo.
A volte ragioniamo con le parole,
altre con le mani:
facciamo laboratori con le mani,
perché le mani pensano
diversamente dalle parole.
Abbiamo bisogno di entrambi gli emisferi
per immaginare le alternative al presente.
Soprattutto, abbandoniamo questa ideologia
oggi imperante, del qui e ora,
che la felicità sia farci bastare
quello che abbiamo.
No! Chi immagina ha fame, sogna,
chi immagina pensa che questo non sia
il migliore dei mondi possibili.
Chi immagina cambia le cose.
Un gruppo di studenti delle superiori
ha fatto un'indagine,
ha somministrato migliaia
di questionari ai loro coetanei,
scoprendo un sacco di malessere:
attacchi di panico, anoressia, bulimia,
disturbi del sonno, psicofarmaci,
ricorso a psicoterapie.
Siamo all'inizio del 2021,
mi chiede una mano per mettere insieme
i dati e presentarli.
Dico: "Sì, ma a patto che non denunciamo
le cose: le cambiamo"
Perché scopriamo che non era la pandemia,
il problema, ma la scuola.
La didattica a distanza
ha bruciato le relazioni
fra docenti e discenti.
Quindi si è creato un clima
di sfiducia, di sospetto:
un sacco di verifiche, di compiti,
al punto che quei ragazzi,
e quelle ragazze,
a marzo/aprile non vogliono
più rientrare a scuola,
perché temono una vendetta
a base di verifiche.
È un paradosso, perché quei ragazzi
prima sognavano di rientrare a scuola.
Non può essere così.
Allora suggerisco di fare
un gruppo misto, studenti e insegnanti,
e scrivere un decalogo
per rientrare insieme a scuola
senza farsi del male.
Per darsi delle regole
di reciproco rispetto,
per dire quali sono i carichi di lavoro
sostenibili di verifiche,
e quant'altro.
Per dire anche che dobbiamo stare attenti,
prima di tutto, alla salute degli altri.
E così succederà: i ragazzi e i docenti
firmeranno quel decalogo.
In questo modo, al rientro a scuola
non accadrà quello che invece
era accaduto a dicembre.
Ecco: se stai male, a 15 anni, a 17 anni,
se senti un "non è giusto",
e i questionari erano pieni
di "non è giusto che",
non è che devi curarti,
non è che devi adattarti.
È il mondo, che va curato.
È la realtà, che va cambiata.
A te spetta immaginarne un'altra.
L'immaginazione di cui parlo è questa.
Non è consolazione,
non è evasione dal presente.
È cambiamento, trasformazione,
progettazione di altri reali possibili.
Un grande filosofo,
Walter Benjamin, diceva:
"Ogni epoca sogna la successiva,
e nel sognarla la rende possibile"
La vera sequenza, quindi,
non è: passato; presente; futuro.
Ecco, questa è un'immagine di Futura.
È il film che abbiamo fatto,
di cui parlava prima Catherine.
Abbiamo ascoltato il racconto di futuro
di ragazzi e ragazze di tutta Italia,
e l'abbiamo portato a Cannes,
perché il mondo sapesse cosa voi pensate
degli anni che ci attendono.
Lo abbiamo fatto,
abbiamo chiesto a tutti e a tutte
qual era la loro idea di futuro.
Perché questo si deve fare.
La vera sequenza è:
passato come repertorio
di possibili che già conosciamo;
il futuro come esercizio
di immaginazione e desiderio;
poi, il presente come realizzazione.
A volte mi chiedo se quello che voi fate,
che è leggere, studiare, viaggiare,
fosse non tanto per saperne di più
ma per avere più immaginazione
per poter davvero cambiare il presente
e realizzare qualcosa
di quello che noi vediamo,
diverso da quello che noi vediamo.
"È facile per te", mi dice qualcuno.
"Si vede che sei del segno dei Pesci",
alludendo al fatto che noi dei Pesci
siamo un po' per aria.
Io rispondo: "Intanto,
sono ascendente Toro".
(Risate)
E poi, forse è solo questione
di non tradire la mia età,
la propria infanzia e adolescenza.
Grazie.
(Applausi)